accor les liaisons dangereuses lui par
jean paul gaultier
le couturier qui a toutes les audaces
même celle de choisir des mannequins qui
ne sont plus des jeunes filles en fleur
il vient de dévoiler sa collection
d'hiver yauba grégoire était là
mais non c'est pas agressif en attaque
aussi des filles est un spectacle qu'il
règle comme un chef d'orchestre tout le
monde doute y être c'est le must le
défilé auquel on doit assister jean paul
gaultier on a mal on déteste mais on
vient
ne serait ce que pour le délire un côté
spectaculaire qui peut être mais qui
peut paraître provocateur et agressif
mais en vérité ce sont ces mêmes
vêtements que je présente d'une certaine
façon la faune après dans l'éditique et
ils sont portables puisqu'on l'effort il
est le deuxième dans le peloton des
créateurs qui vend le plus 500 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les américains en parle comme d'un
phénomène dans le défilé une journaliste
un homme travesti sa cousine je suis dit
qu'en fin de compte y avait pas que le
type même qu'un l'archétype du mannequin
traditionnelle qui était bien mais aussi
d'autres formes de beauté j'essaye de
les montrer c'est sans fin de compte je
crois que ce toucher à ces prêts en fin
de compte de ce qui se passe dans la rue
ce que je fais c'est pour quand le
vêtement soit portée c'est la rue qui
m'intéresse c'est la vie en falcon un
vêtement dans un musée ou un vêtement
sur un simple c'est la mort gauthier
fait ça pour rire mais pas du tout il a
sens de l'humour jeu aucun sens de
l'humour quatre mille personnes sous la
halle de la villette on ne se précipite
pas pour rien il ne s'amuse peut-être
pas mais nous oui
j'ai aucun sens et limoges suis
quelqu'un de si près en mieux
non j'ai quelqu'un de travail
pas facile à porter surtout à leur tête